hello everybody my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel on how to
survive in the online jungle today we're
going to be talking about a very
important aspect of cyber security
cryptocurrencies and the blockchain now
it's commonly believed the bitcoin and
other kinds of cryptocurrency are
anonymous and therefore they can be used
to pay for illegal endeavors on darkness
right hiring hackers buying illegal
goods or laundering money but you'd be
surprised to find out that they aren't
all that anonymous after all
mr roger stevens
so bitcoin itself is rather like a
bulletproof glass safe of course it's
difficult to steal valuables from it but
everybody around it can see what's
inside now i doubt you'd agree to walk
around in a t-shirt with your bank
statement on it right or publish your
family budgets in the morning newspaper
so look let's figure out together how to
avoid the trap of pseudonymity in the
confusing world of cryptocurrencies and
the blockchain
[Music]
so to understand why bitcoin itself is
vulnerable you first need to understand
how it works and that's really where
this problem comes in very often expert
explanations regarding algorithms of
these complex programs can become well
boring lectures to understand them you
have to be familiar with all sorts of
mathematical analysis you have to deal
with a huge number of terms and just
frankly scary words surely you've come
across this before i mean explanations
that hinder your understanding as
opposed to helping it
therefore today i'm going to try and
tell you about cryptocurrencies and the
blockchain as simply as possible now if
you're an expert on bitcoin erythium or
cheer this may not be the place for you
but you can safely move on to next
chapter so let's imagine that our good
friend upside down friend lucas right
decides to try his hand in the financial
business he takes 100 000 us dollars
from the bank and invests it in various
businesses of his friends now let's say
lucas has a bad memory and he doesn't
trust computers so he keeps all of his
investment records on a good
old-fashioned notepad now his entries
will look something like this
took a bank loan right plus a hundred
thousand invested in a car rental
company minus thirty thousand invested
in bradley's translation agency minus
ten thousand and invested in a travel
agency twenty thousand so everything is
pretty simple and clear as if it were a
family budget but now imagine that i got
my hands on this notebook well with just
one swift swipe of my secret eraser i no
longer owe lucas ten thousand dollars
for his investment into my translation
company i just hacked into lucas's
payment system so is it possible to
protect yourself from such tricks you
could add a control code to each record
for example count the number of
characters in each line and write down a
total at the end of the line see took a
bank loan 27 invested in a car rental
company 42 invested in bradley's
translation agency 50
invested in a travel agency 37. so now
it's much more difficult to change the
record if i were to just erase a zero
from my debt lucas would see that the
number of characters in the line doesn't
match the control value for the line now
that would be a clear sign of forgery
but surely i could just erase the whole
line right both the amount of the debt
and the checksum and then lucas would be
none the wiser
[Music]
well the council measures this is quite
simple make sure that each line is
connected to one another
you can do this by adding the number of
characters from the line before to the
number of characters of the line in
question now what you get is combined
total which will feature at the end of
the line itself took a bank loan 27
invested in a car rental company 69
invested in bradley's translation agency
92 invested in a travel agency 87.
you see now the checksum protects not
only its own data but also that of the
previous row now if i were to erase the
entire row lucas would notice that
there's missing data now here's
something else
lucas also likes round sums he wants all
of these control numbers to end with
zero therefore he decides to add
additional characters to the line to
make sure there are no ugly entries
right now let's look what we've got took
a bank loan 30 invested in a car rental
company 70 invested in bradley's
translation agency 100 invested in a
travel agency 90. now in a nutshell
that's kind of how bitcoin works of
course it doesn't count characters but
it does use a special mathematical
function that is easy to calculate in
one direction and difficult to calculate
in the other it's a bit like squaring
the number i don't know 23. it's pretty
easy right you just need to multiply it
by itself but it's much more difficult
to move in the opposite direction or in
our case find the root for 529. one-way
transformations are called hash
functions and they fittingly result in
hashes and of course since the control
function relies on its complexity it's
rather difficult to make it beautiful
additional characters that allow the
hash to end with a pair of zeros are
called cryptographic nonces numbers that
can be used only once with bitcoin
several users are searching for these
nonces at any one time it's almost like
a lock picking race right now whoever
calculates the nonce first gets rewarded
now this lock picking race is called
bitcoin mining which i'm sure you've
heard of
now each record of money movement in
lucas's notebook is a transaction and
together with the calculated control
values it becomes a block right so the
sequence or chain of such blocks is
called the block chain fittingly you see
it's not really that complicated after
all this algorithm was actually first
described in 1998 in the works of wei
dai and nick sabo now independently of
one another they came up with the ideas
of b money and bit gold cryptocurrencies
as we know them however appeared only 10
years later
[Laughter]
now on january the 9th of 2009 a man who
is still hiding under the pseudonym of
satoshi nakamoto published the very
first version of this system by
implementing anonymity he had hoped that
this service would enable people to set
up electronic wallets but without having
to give out their personal details the
potential for unpunished transferring of
legal funds didn't really occur to him
at that point the idea was that
cryptographic information would really
replace your real data all records of
money transfers remain in the system
forever they're stored on computers of
millions of people around the world and
it's actually mathematically impossible
to remove even an individual block of
this chain but it is possible to trace
the transfers from wallet to wallet the
amount of data is incomprehensibly huge
right but it is open to analysis on the
web you can even find online block
analyzers for example on
blockstream.info from this data set if
the analyst's time and abilities allow
for it lots of interesting information
can be squeezed out firstly there are
inputs right the sources of digital
money the wallets from which the
cryptocurrency is sent now secondly
there are outputs now these are the
recipient wallets right to which the
cryptocurrency is sent and finally the
exact times of these transactions are
also displayed now of course this isn't
exactly a link to your facebook page but
it's certainly a step towards it so look
let's say i returned that debt to lucas
but i did it in bitcoin
now he'll see my transaction input that
is the source of funds relating to my
transaction but i will be able to see
his output that is when and to whom he
will send that currency is that
anonymity i mean what if instead of
to lucas's wallet i sent that payment to
a fake nsa or fbi address
right we call it you the candy okay
gotti all right kenny
i don't know if you guys have heard
about the colonial pipeline ransomware
attack it happened earlier this year now
the specialists of the ministry of
justice have already retrieved 63 of the
75 bitcoins that that company paid to
extortionists both inputs and outputs
can be highlighted and subsequently
de-anonymized such lists are actually
meticulously maintained by analytics
companies and they're often leaked into
public access you can actually gain
access to these lists by the dark net
using bitcoin but you can probably guess
why you shouldn't do that i mean because
of these features bitcoin is often
referred to as a glass safe records of
transactions are almost impossible to
fake but you can examine the contents of
your wallet in detail making a schedule
of income and expenses right yes
anonymity
forget it
[Music]
analysts also use something called data
clustering this is where they analyze
all the data on inputs and outputs they
build chains and they also combine
similar transactions here too there's
something that i've talked to about more
than once right and that is that the
more actions you perform the more traces
of you are left now the more traces of
view there are the easier it is for
people to distinguish you from other
users of the system your transactions
effectively leave a digital footprint in
the same way that a set of fonts might
or browser plugins right now
transactions are made up of a variety of
factors we've got inputs and outputs
we've got analyses of the connections
between specific addresses inside the
chain we've got comparisons of sums and
also time intervals of transactions the
enormous computational costs of
searching for similar operations are
justified by the fact that the
denomination of just one address leads
by default to the denomination of all
interacting parties
and therefore real attackers never use
the same wallet for different tasks and
for important things in general wallets
are actually created just for one-time
use to add to this there are mixer
services now these are services that
allow one to confuse their digital
footprint by mixing bitcoins between
subscribers of a certain service
according to a random algorithm payments
are split up combined transferred many
times through fake outputs and as a
result it becomes much more difficult to
unravel this trail there are also some
software tricks that come into play for
example the manual selection of inputs
for specific transactions a software ban
on duplicate addresses and so on but all
these methods are useless if we consider
bitcoin as an autonomous system we don't
actually pay attention to web security
in general
[Music]
but it's important to note most bitcoin
transactions can be tracked easily
without these tricks i mean the
vulnerability is in how you spend your
cryptocurrency
for example when you pay for something
in real life let's say a pizza with
bitcoin more often than not you're
sending money to an organization that
knows you outside of the blockchain
because of this if you're trying to pay
for something like a pizza using crypto
let's say using money that you've
gathered illegally then it really
wouldn't be difficult to link you to an
illicit transaction on the blockchain
right anonymity and online shopping
really don't go hand in hand in addition
bitcoin transactions are most often
transmitted in encrypted packets right
over the regular internet this means
that your real ip address is relatively
easy to determine i will find you
and i will hack you now the same problem
appears with payments via blockchain or
coinbase wallets and in this case
companies that process such transactions
have detailed logs with ip addresses and
other information that just gives you
away
and don't forget about the logs that
your internet provider keeps right
linking cryptographic activity with your
identity
is really trivial but look before you go
praying to
for complete blockchain anonymity it's
important to remember that
de-anonymizing transfers can be
beneficial not just for the police but
for you too there's actually a really
cool startup that i learned about it's
called whalemap.io now they use on-chain
analytics to understand who is holding
vast amounts of bitcoin and where that
bitcoin is being sent now this
information is very useful to investment
banks but also people like you and i
who'd like to make a pound or two of the
intensely thought out actions of real
players on the cryptocurrency market
what should you do if you do want to
keep your payments anonymous firstly you
can use more secure cryptocurrencies
bitcoin really hasn't made any steps in
the past few years to become more
private but there are means of payment
that were initially designed for maximum
secrecy for example zcash reliably
protects all of your payment details old
timers of the dark web can probably
recall another system known under three
names actually darkcoin xcoin and dash
right now this principle is similar to
mixers each transaction is mixed up up
to eight times with transactions of
other cryptocurrency users unfortunately
law enforcement agencies pay special
attention to transactions with such
payment systems as you can imagine so
unwittingly you can get completely
unnecessary interest in your activities
just because you've chosen to use a
service for its anonymity and lastly if
you do decide to use bitcoin don't
forget to take a look at our videos on
anonymity and the stupid mistakes of
hackers you'll really enjoy them i mean
it's always better to learn from the
mistakes of others right not that you
guys are hacking or doing anything shady
right
anyway look i can only wish you good
luck in your legitimate endeavors right
my name is bradley peak and this has
been a bright bountiful vociferous brad
venture into the world of the online
jungle i will see you in the next video
by the way guys the next video will be
something that i hope will be incredibly
interesting i don't remember but about a
month ago i posted an invitation to
action where you guys could comment if
you wanted us to find out interesting
information about you we've actually now
selected the candidates and
we are currently investigating them as
we speak so hopefully the next video is
going to be really cool so tune in and
maybe you'll see yourself and your
facebook profile on screen
hello my name is bradley and this is
some subs bitcoin mixing blending show
now bitcoin is fancy enough but the real
question is will it blend